que en teoría están tratando de hacerlo
están siendo limitados.
Pero quizás aún más importante,
hemos oído antes del 1 %,
del 99 %.
Si el Estado se pensara de esta forma estratégica,
como uno de los jugadores principales en el mecanismo de creación de valor,
porque de eso estamos hablando, ¿sí?
Quiénes son los diferentes actores en la creación de valor
en la economía y el papel del Estado,
y cómo se lo ha relegado a un segundo plano.
Si podemos tener una teoría más amplia
de creación de valor que nos permita admitir
lo que el Estado ha estado haciendo y obtener algo a cambio,
podría ser en la próxima ronda,
y espero que todos esperemos que la siguiente gran revolución
de hecho sea ecológica,
que ese período de crecimiento
no solo sea inteligente, basado en la innovación,
no solo ecológico, sino también más inclusivo,
para que las escuelas públicas en lugares como Silicon Valley
pueden beneficiarse de ese crecimiento,
porque no lo han hecho.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)